どうもみなさんこんにちはご紹介いただきました中身です
今日はですねあの研究の話をしようかと思ったんですけれども
せっかくがこういう機会をいただきましたので
まあ私自身も慶応高校の出身ですので
この一貫教育校の高校生に何を伝えたいかということを考えて今日はこういうタイトル
にさせていただきました
500万円の回もというタイトルですまあこの意味は
その後の地位お分かりいただけるかと思いますがまずは自己紹介からさせていただき
ました
私は1988年の生まれでしてへましょうはの最後の年のオフまでです
今ここにいる4寒いの平成の生まれたと思いますけれども多くは昭和の最後の前という
ことで高校から栄養技術に入りました
その後は環境情報学部 hdfc ですね
に進学をしましてそのまま大学院政策メディアの
を修士課程博士が前としてみまして3月に博士の学院を取得もして卒業しました
今は株式会社メタ人というところに努めております
株式会社下手ジェンというのは町内祭神の研究をやっているような会社なんですけれど
もそこがホームでありまして
視聴金で政策メディア研究科の状況
いうポジションの
やっております
私の8月からですねまぁあの学生時代温泉の研究を結構やっていたものですから
このですね日本健康果樹怠惰の温泉科学研究所というところから
連携研究者というふうに一命をして頂いておりま
あの連休の話でもですねお楽しみいただけることもあるかと思うんですけれどもそれは
また別の機会にということで今日は
方向性に良い伝えたいメッセージを持ってまいりました
皆さんちょっと考えていただきたいんですけれども500万円を手に入れたらどういう
風に使えますか
ぜひ高校生の皆さんに今子ですね真剣に考えていただきているんですけれども
500もらいなったら何をしたいんですかどうやって使えますか
ちょっと考えてみてください
何かアイディアが思いついた人がいたら教えてほしいなと思うんですが
どういう風に使ってみたいか
れていただけますかなぁ
一度平野のかう
梅の日と聞いてもいいですかはい
は真ん中の
使いたいですか
なんでもいいですよ
こんなの超近ですね堅実な実に現実な使い方ですけれども
使いましょうよブーバ風に考えた時にオープンを考えていきましたけれども
例えば車を買おうといった時にベンツにょ筆頭だと思いますけど
お車も帰っ
家帰るんですね5北山形県鶴岡市ってとこに研究者そこに住んでんですけれども
ちょっと古いですよ古いですけど6 dk とかで買えますから
500枚あるといえも感じます
それからですねまぁ海外旅行でも行こうかと思って考えるともう一回25巻くらいと
考えて20回もいけるんですね
なかなかいろんな使い道があります
から世界一周旅行度かもねをご調べてみたんですけどクイーンビクトリアというの豪華
客船ですけどこれ121日間か
バルコニー付きの部屋で500もないですね大体これぐらい前か一周旅行にも行って
いく
これからコンビニの商品全部買い占める500万くらい出せるんですね
哀れちょっとヤフーやグーグルとかを見たんで本当かどうか分かりませんけれども
ワゴンなぐらいの使い方があったということですはかなりいろんな使い方ができますよ
ね100万円あったら相当なことができます
高校生のみなさんは
今500万円の使い道を考えるときです
というか
500万円の買い物せざるを得ない状況と言い方がいいかもしれませんけれども
何を言ってるのかというと僕が言いたいのはこれなんですね
学部を選ぶということは500万円の買い物をするということと同義じゃないかなと僕
は思っております
まあいい学部とかちょっと桁違いに高いんですけれどもだいたいどこの額が入っても
大体500万ぐらいかかるんですね
ねえええもうちょっとどこが高いとかっていうのは別にいいんですけれどもそういう
ことではなくて皆さんが今考えてほしいのは
これから皆さんは必ず500万に使って今後のボンヌ4年間を過ごすんですね
その時にどこへ行くかということを
さっき500万円どういう風に使いますかって言って
をそれなりに楽しんで真剣に考えてくれたんじゃないかと思うんですが
同じぐらいのテンションで楽しく真剣に考えてますかということを言いたいんですね
僕自身を
そこまで本気で高校戦時考えていたかと言われると怪しい部分もあるし不安の当時を
振り返って周りを見ていてもそんなに本気で考えてみたかと言われるとちょっと怪しい
部分が
やっぱり大学を卒業して今になって思うことは
やっぱり学部を選ぶということは非常に大事なことであってその後の人生に影響があり
ます
でまた一貫教育校の皆さんは受験することなく
学部を選べるわけですね
そういう恵まれた環境にいるということを
きちんと自覚をしていただいて
楽しく絵なんてはしですね自分の将来を考えてどういうふうに過ごしていきたいかと
いうことをぜひ高校生の時にちゃんと考えたんです
そういうふうに思っています
このためには大学を出てどういうふうになりたいかという将来像を
信徒以外てほしい
人生80年クレット考えると大学に在籍している時間というのはたった4年間
ですね
5%んです当たった5%と考えるか
5%もあると考えるかはいろいろな考え方があると思いますけれども
その4年間は通過点ですよ
4年からしかありませんねその4年間どういうふうに通過していってどういうふうに
なりたいのか
その将来像はできちんと考えてほしいなと思うんですね
とはいえ
高校生の皆さんに将来どうなりたいのかと
5年後10年後を考えてと言ってもなかなか難しい部分もあると思いますけれども
今この時点で可能な限り良い
真剣に考えるということが大事なのではないかと
メイクつかの学部は資格を取ることができますね
逆にその資格が必要な職業に就きたいという場合には自動的に選ぶこともあるかと思い
ます
医師になりたければいい学名いただければならないし薬剤師になりたければ薬学部は
いかなければならない
看護師になりたければ関学がいいかなければなこういうことはあるかもしれませんが
重要なことは
この医師になりたいといった場合に石ってどんな仕事かということをよく考えて決め
ましたかということをもう一度考えてほしいんですね
イメージと興味だけで選んでしまうと実際にそう職業に就いた時に大変なことになる
こともあると思うんです
私自身も高校生の時に
現役の医師の方とお話をしたりする機会がたまたまあって
私自身がそういうふうに思ってなかったんですが現役の臨床をやっている医師の方は
医者はサービス業だよということを言う方が結構いらっしゃったんですね
私はそういう風には考えなかったので高校生と結構衝撃を受けました
なので実際にその職に就いている方の話を聞いてみたりすると今皆さんがイメージして
いることとは違った見方ができるかもしれません
彼らはがきちんとですねそういう現実に働いている方の話を聞いてみるとかそういう
ことも非常に重要になってくるんじゃないかなと思います
ブービー+たいかということをイメージして a どんな仕事に就きたいかあそのため
に同学部 a 一体化ということを決めて欲しいなと思っているんですけども ok
アニェッリところに言いますけれどもそこの高校生とかありますその日あのどういう
ふうにスチロ進めて
したいかということを問われた時にはよくこういうふうに言います範囲で考えたらどう
ですか
いうことを言います
どういう意味かというと
今皆さんにピンポイントでこの職に就きたいというのを決めろというのなかなか無理が
あると思うんですね
ただ自分の興味がある範囲っていうのはある程度絞れるんじゃないかなと
例えば医療系の仕事に就きたいという
を言った場合に逆にそこからこれはやりたくないなということで絞っていくということ
もできると思うんですね医療系の仕事に就きたいけれども
例えばちょっとどうしても血を見るのや中で手術はいけないなと
医者わぁ外そうかなってソースと薬剤師かなみたいな話になってランクを絞りてくるん
じゃないかと思うんですか
ん
あとはいえまだまだ皆さんが知っている世界には
ああ
限られた世界だと思いますので
実はその範囲を決めた後その範囲の中にある仕事というのは数国がたくさんあると思う
んですね
例えば医療系の仕事をしたいといった場合に臨床検査技師という
血液の検査をするような仕事の方とか
理学療法士てリハビリテーションのお手伝いをする方とか
いろんな方がいらっしゃるわけですもっと言うと医療器具も作る仕事とかいうあるわけ
ですね
そういうのも十分に医療に貢献をしているわけです
やりたい範囲というのを決めるとその中に何があるのかというのがそこからも調べ方
次第で見えてくると思うんですね
いろいろ考えても今決めたと考えて決めたことっていうのはじっと
どんどん視野が広がっていくにつれて変わってしまうと思いますがそれで良いと思い
ますので現時点でよく考えて決断は
ブーブー言っにょいいんじゃないかと思いますので
そういうふうに考えてもらえるといいんじゃないか
さっきも言いましたけれども
なかなか表から見えない仕事っていうのも世の中にはたくさんあると思うんですね
今上段の公益社のドラマとかもやってますけれども
まあいう形で代表されるように表に見えない仕事っていうのが非常にたくさんあると
思います
そういうのが皆さんの興味に遭うかもしれないので
ぜひ良いですね色んなことに興味を持ってそういう
このも見ていってほしいというふうに思います
平和ちなみに自分がどうだったかというようなことを話しを
清めて行きたいと思いますけれどもまあなんで凶暴いう話をしているのかというのも
この自分の体験に基づいているんですが自分はですね
まだ高校生の時は理工学部いった風でした
高校3年生の夏までもう何となくに工学部に言うんだろうなと理科が好きでしたので
理工学部に行くんだろうなと思ってました
まあその理由としてはなんとなく医薬品をつくってみたいなと思っていたんですね
じゃなんで薬学部じゃないのと言うと僕の土地は約6まま出なかった
んですね
あったら言っただと思いますけれども僕の次の学変換薬学部に進学ができて
できるようになったんですね
断裁売却額土中選択肢は最初に何かのかんですけどなくてエヴァ理科学部に行くと思っ
ています
でただですねあのさっき[ __ ]回もしてもらいましたがアグ酒その前にこれ高校3年生
の時の時間はいよう
見つけ出して持ってきたんですけれども8
2年生まではですね気象予報士になろうかなと思っていて地学ばっかりだったんですね
まぁちょっとでもいろいろ心変わりもあって3年生の時に突然生物やろうと思って
2年生の生物やってなかったので生物 i と生物にを3年前に同時にとりました
あーー構造的なんですけども
当時も相当
無理を言ってこっちの生物1っていうのは一人受けていました
あの担当の先生にはこの日オフさえいなければ4件で帰れるのにとか言われながら
号弦6弦をすいませんやって下さいと言ってですね
一人で受けて生物をやっていたんですけれども
まぁこんなようなところで高校3連部生物にもちょっと興味が湧いてきて
またが理工学部の生命情報学科に行こうというふうに思っていたんですよ
ただその時に夏にこれを見ましたけいおんサマーバイオカレッジ2006と言って栄養
の sfc の研究所に先端生命科学研究所9山形県鶴岡市にありますけれども
ここでリアル体験のイベントがあるというチラシをもらいました
僕は正直その当時理工学部に行くと
決めていまして他に生物ができるところがあるということすら考えてもいませんでした
し
これを見たときもアイエスエフシーなんだかなと
まぁいいかって言ってましたこれは情色してたんですけれどもこの
科学にの正しいで言う先生がいい
この2005兄引率をしたという授業中に話をしてくれたんですねでこれなかなかいい
と生物をやる子があるやつはこれに行ってみたらいいんじゃないかといったんですねっ
もそういう人日本ホメロスメロスったように記憶して言うのであっう先生が
いいと言うんだったら相当いいんだろうなと思って
これに行ってみたんですね
そこでをが衝撃を受けてこの山形へ行きました
ん
2廊下の研究所へ行って
理工学部の堅殻も行きましたけれども雰囲気が地全然違うなと思ったんですねあの良い
悪いということではなくて雰囲気が全然違うので
僕には少なくてもこの釣ろうかの研究所が非常に合っているなと思ったので
sfc に進学するということをじめましてこれもねあのよく写真のことだなと思い
ますけど
あと進学願いの一番最初に環境情報学部と書いて出しました
でパレス fc に進学をしたわけですね
ですから僕はの方の sbc というイベントがなければまたあの科学の誰か宣伝部
人事がなければセーフシーに進学することはなかった思います
逆に言うとそのきっかけがなかったとしたらまともに家んと情報収集を制作考えてい
なかったからこそ
これいかなかったらどうなってたんだろうなと思ってしまうわけです
ですからぜひ皆さんにはそういう危ない橋を渡らずにですね
しっかり情報収集をしてどこに何があってどこにいろんな先生がいてどういう研究が
できる
どこ行ったらどういう将来につながるということを真剣に考えてほしいというのが多い
んですね
snc で行くと1年生から研究ができますので仏法に年制学部2年生の時に
日本分子生物学会というところでポスターが発表させてもらいました
だからあの
果物をたくさんありますのでメーカーの味になると果物がいいとか言ったりして結構
プライベントも楽しく過ごせますし冬になる場所のもとに行ったり好き
教授と一緒に行った印象なんですね大楽しい生活も持っています
だから最終的には5温泉の言及をしてましてですね温泉を飲んだ時に
腸内細菌はどう変わるのかっていうようなテーマ人で
博士ロングルームトップだしたんですけれども
その時もですね多いだけどだけた c というところでありましたが
竹田市町と並んで私ここにいるんですけども記者会見をしてメディアに研究の成果を
アピールしたいとそういうようなこともさせてもらいましたし
これはブラジルの温泉系の学科へ行ってですね
この
open discussion みたいな形で私ここにいますけれども
著名な科学者と一緒に並んで発表するといういろんなこともさせてもらいました
こういう研究ができるのもうあたり私自身は sfc に進んで自分に合った環境で
撃沈と楽しく研究ができたからだなと思っていますのでぜひ皆さんもですねこれは私に
とってはこの sbg なかったらどうなっていたのかということを
非常に今7
紅白もありという形で思っていますので皆さん1きちんとの
これからの500前の使い方をよく考えて進学大外を出してくださいというのが僕の
共同メッセージです以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]